hi I'm Erik Bosse and with the ventures
infinity war behind us the countdown to
Avengers 4 has begun and we're starting
to get some more details we think a big
one I want to talk about in this video
is the idea that the next movie could
feature a character named Chronos so who
is this guy why don't we think it could
be important Chronos is a cosmic entity
from the Marvel Comics the cosmic
entities are a number of godlike beings
who exist as part of the universe itself
many of them are intangible and their
powers aren't really on a scale with the
characters that we know I'm talking
about characters like The Living
Tribunal he's a massive three-face judge
character who keeps all the cosmic laws
in check actually in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline of the comics which
the infinity war movie was partially
based on The Living Tribunal is actually
brought into the Thanos storyline the
other cosmic entities want the Living
Tribunal to judge Thanos because of all
the war crimes he's committing but the
Libya Tribunal refuses because in his
rationale Thanos hasn't technically
broken any laws Stannis is just
following the general law that the
strong should replace the weak The
Living Tribunal gosh shout out in the
MCU in the movie Doctor Strange the
staff of the Living Tribunal was the
name of a mystical object that Mordo
used to train strange and come our Tosh
now just to give you some context
another cosmic entity is called eternity
that's a little hard to explain eternity
is a character that embodies all of time
and space and life and death essentially
the universe itself
some believe that guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 gave a shout-out to
eternity remember when ego opened Peter
Quill's eyes to the mysteries of the
universe oh and speaking of ego he is
another type of cosmic entity it's
called a celestial in the comics the
Celestials are an advanced alien race
sort of who created mutant kind the
x-men now the MCU version of Celestials
appears a little different for example
ego described himself as a brain
floating alone in space eventually
created life around himself
anyway this brings us back to Chronos
now Chronos is an eternal it's a race
created by the Celestials their
evolutionary offshoots of humans with
powers and longer lifespans kind of like
the end humans but not the same thing
now Chronos was an eternal who
experimented with cosmic energy
merging him with time he is the master
of time he can slow down time he can
stop time generally work time you can
put time down
in Reverse time that's pretty bad
Chronos is also thanassis grandfather
they anos along with his father and his
mother are all each Colonels as well
Chronos his son was a Lars who was
actually mentioned by Red Skull infinity
war he greeted that oh says son of
in-laws now Chronos founded Titan that
Stannis is home planet that was
destroyed by overpopulation which was
the major setting in infinity war now
Kronos was a creation by comic book
artist jim Starlin recently Starlin
spoke at a panel in puerto rico where a
reporter quoted him as saying that he
would be receiving a credit for another
one of his marvel creations and Avengers
war and Chronos seemed like the most
obvious pic he's directly related to
Thanos and he controls time which seems
like it would be a useful tool in the
Avengers final battle against Thanos but
but but even more recently jim Starlin
clarified his comments he said that he
was actually misquoted that it came up
that he received two character credits
and Infinity Ward and that he joked that
he would shoot for three in Avengers 4
but let's be honest theories about
Chronos and of interest for began long
before Starlin was misquoted Cronus
could present some really interesting
story possibilities for Avengers 4
imagine a cosmic force intervening in
the Avengers conflict revealing himself
to Tony Stark as Thanos his grandfather
rendering judgment on his mad Titans
grandson so now he's backing the other
side perhaps we'll learn that during
Doctor Strange his glances into those 14
million different futures he communed
with Chronos who counselled strange to
allow events to transpire in a specific
way so that in the end game Chronos
could help a specific line up Avengers
by rewinding them to past conflicts to
reset the timeline in a way to even the
odds against his wayward grandson by the
way after Thanos acquired the time stone
remember Strange told Stark the line
we're in the endgame now and you may
have seen that Avengers endgame came up
recently as a possible title for
Avengers 4 because the cinematographer
on these movies listed Avengers in game
on his official credits before changing
it mysteriously now it's not clear if
endgame was just a working title for the
movie since the Russo brothers have
confirmed that the title for Avengers 4
would not be a line of dialogue from
infinity war Marvel head Kevin Feige has
said that the title would be revealed
after the first trailer for Captain
Marvel
sometime in the next few months but
getting back to Kronos of course cosmic
entities have been used sparingly in the
MCU they're really hard to wrap your
brain around for average viewers and for
nerds honestly but more importantly they
create stakes problems for these movies
when literally the entire universe is at
stake it's kind of hard to understand
the emotional reaction to that from the
character point of view for example as
we saw in Fantastic Four rise of the
Silver Surfer Galactus who is another
cosmic entity was just too huge and
amoral for us to register him as an
intimate emotional threat to the heroes
now guardians vol 2 actually got around
that by making ego really vain and
selfish with a strong emotional
connection to Peter quill and some
really clever exposition scenes to help
clarify his even existence and actor
Kurt Russell displays all of his
characters with a humanity that we all
immediately connect with
so if Chronos does appear in the MCU
they wouldn't be wise to also make him a
quirky human figure that we can relate
to and if we're looking back in the
comics for inspiration here's one fun
idea go meta the most powerful cosmic
entity in the Marvel Comics is a figure
called the one above all he or she here
it is a god-like being whose true form
it's never seen the one above all just
takes various forms then one of those
forms was artist Jack Kirby himself that
comic issue zoomed out from a comic
panel to show him in his studio drawing
Fantastic Four comics it was pretty
awesome so if we're looking at this from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
wouldn't it be a hoot for that cosmic
entity the one above all or Crono serve
anyone else to be played by Stan Lee
just think about it the guy has already
appeared in pretty much every movie with
Marvel characters and a Guardians vol 2
we actually saw him yucking it up with
these guys now these are called the
Watchers there are also cosmic entities
who observe and record all the events in
the universe and there was actually a
theory going around at the time that
Stan Lee could be uatu the watcher sure
Stan Lee isn't an actor but his many
cameos have made him a familiar face to
everyone who sees these movies and his
appearance as a cosmic entity who
conducts divine intervention with the
Avengers to help them defeat Thanos
could offset any of this cosmic
backstory that could alienate some
viewers so here you have it and the 14
million one odds that Chronos happens to
appear in Avengers 4 and it's played by
Stan Lee you heard it here first but a
question for you guys in Avengers 4
would you prefer this kind of
intervention from a cosmic entity or
should the adventures just handle things
on their own comment down below with
your thoughts or tweet me directly at EA
boss and follow new rockstars on Twitter
for updates on our videos like this
video share it around and subscribe to
new rockstars for deep dives and do the
Avengers and the whole Marvel Cinematic
Universe hand for our speculation on
which crazy crap from the comics they
could try to adapt into the big screen
thanks for watching
[Music]